[Música]
o pessoal tudo bem é queria falar com
vocês hoje sobre privacidade e proteção
de dados no brasil mas para entender
como o sistema começa eu preciso levar
adiante uma história trabalho com esse
tema nessa interface entre direito e
tecnologia há bastante tempo a mais de
20 anos e lá atrás exatamente em 2001 eu
notei algo curioso no meio do escritório
eu começava a receber muito spam
para quem não se lembra expansão aquelas
mensagens indesejáveis que chegavam o
chegam à nossa caixa eletrônica que vão
ocupando o nosso dia a gente tentar
apagar tudo aquilo lá atrás 2001 eu
recebi de tudo venda de produtos
príncipes nigerianos exilados queriam me
ajuda para recuperar o seu património
como agente especial
aquilo que começou a me incomodar então
pedi a um estagiário que fosse até o
camelódromo é o centro de comércio
popular da uruguaiana no centro do rio
ele comprasse um cd para mandar spam no
que que é isso um cd que possuía milhões
de e mails através dos quais você
conseguia mandar uma mala direta para
pessoas que nunca ouviram falar de você
nem queriam receber aquela mensagem a
gente pode até questionar se isso é
lícito ou ilícito
o motivo pelo qual eu pedi que o
estagiário fosse é comprar não eu
se eu não falar nada de relevante até o
final da exposição eu queria passar uma
lição de vida para vocês
esse estagiário virou meu chefe então
gente tratem bem o seu estagiário ele um
dia pode ser o seu chefe
nesse e mail para mandar spam é claro
que lá estava o meu e-mail do escritório
e aí eu percebi ao curioso o fato de que
alguém estava pagando exatamente dez
reais pra mandar uma mensagem para
milhões de pessoas e também pra mim
o cd é segmentado e mails de
funcionários do banco do brasil e mails
de pessoas do escritório jurídico
com formação jurídica e isso me chamou
muito a atenção lá atrás em 2001 alguém
pagava uma fração de centavos para ter
acesso a um dado pessoal meu pergunta é
será que isso não é ilícito o que tem de
errado nisso aqui
será que o meu estado estão sendo
violados para entender isso a gente tem
que dar um passo atrás e procurar saber
como privacidade e proteção de dados se
tornam direitos e como nós podemos lutar
por eles porque no caso do meu e mail do
escritório era muito simples bastava
cancelar aquela conta de email e começar
uma nova mas quando a gente vai falar
sobre dados pessoais talvez fique cada
vez mais difícil apagar e começar de
novo
vamos entender como é que começa a
estudar essa questão quando a gente
pensa em privacidade e da cidade vai se
tornar um direito só no século 19 mas
isso não quer dizer que no século 19 as
pessoas descobriram a privacidade não
mostrou contrário ao longo da história a
gente tem diversas situações em que a
privacidade aparece como um sentimento
como algo que as pessoas desejam aspiram
então a gente for ler a ilíada de homero
lá existe momento em que aqueles briga
com agamenon por conta é de uma de uma
escrava brisées ida e aqueles passa boa
parte do poema o médico dentro da sua
tenda
e aí não vai lutar na guerra de tróia se
recusa a lutar
aquela tenda é o lugar dele onde ele tem
privacidade pula um salto histórico
caímos no século 18 talvez um dos
personagens mais públicos o rei francês
também tinha desejo por privacidade
a gente dá uma olhadinha no mapa do
palácio de versalhes
a gente vai perceber que lá no meio da
floresta o rei mandou construir o reluz
15 manda construir um petit trianon né
uma edificação para a sua amante a
madame de kompa do então até mesmo a
figura mais pública também quer ter
privacidade
mas nada disso era um direito a primeira
vez que direito à privacidade aparece
assim conceituado em 1891 ter chamado
the bright provas e dois juristas samuel
ordem e luiz brandeis a forma pela qual
privacidade aparece é a seguinte a
privacidade é um direito ao isolamento
o direito a estar só a se destacar da
sociedade
e aí a pergunta é muito bem será que
essa é a privacidade que a gente quer
hoje será que essa é a privacidade que a
gente hoje em dia é pretende lutar por
ela
as coisas mudaram muito e ao lado da
privacidade a proteção de dados pessoais
começa a se tornar cada vez mais
presente no nosso dia a dia
talvez alguns de vocês conheçam esse
caso americano da loja de departamento
target a loja de departamento tarde
através de um big data o tratamento de
grande volume de dados dos seus clientes
descobrir o que clientes um mulheres 2
que trocam o creme hidratante com o
cheiro para creme hidratante sem cheiro
e que compram também suplementos de
zinco se esses três fatores se unirem
trata grávida e aí a loja pode mandar
cupom de desconto de berço enxoval para
garantir que o enxoval será comprado na
loja como vocês podem imaginar se pode
dar muito certo ou muito errado nesse
caso aqui bastante conhecido os cupons
de desconto foram enviados para casa
dessa menina de 16 anos o pai
interceptou e disse
mas como estão mandando esse tipo de
cupom enfim minha filha não está grávida
bom poucas semanas depois quando vocês
podem imaginar o pai teve que pedir
desculpas à filha estava grávida e ele
disse é realmente aconteceram coisas
aqui em casa das quais eu não sabia peço
desculpas bom
muita gente diz que o pai sempre o
último a saber mas acho que nesse caso a
gente está colando um pouquinho quando
as lojas de departamentos sabem mais do
que a própria família
essa é a situação de dados sendo
tratados para as mais diferentes
modalidades e isso hoje em dia é a
engrenagem que move uma série de
negócios na internet especialmente redes
sociais
e aí vale aqui um exercício com cada um
de vocês
talvez alguns de vocês tenha conta no
facebook uma das redes sociais mais
famosas mais utilizados no mundo
vocês já foram ver o que o facebook acha
que é o seu interesse o que o facebook
acha que te faz clicar na
coisas nos anúncios vai na configurações
do facebook você vai encontrar um link
para anúncios
é muito interessante então vai lá em
configurações clicam em anúncios ou
preferência de anúncios se você tiver um
celular ou no desktop clicam em anúncios
você vai ver o que o facebook acha que
você gosta
na categoria alimentos e bebidas o
facebook acha que eu gosto de whisky e
de escol
eu não sou uma pessoa de deste lado na
verdade nem tomar uísque e pergunta se
isso foi útil para você
acho que não na categoria esportes
facebook acha que eu gosto de futebol
triatlo
não não é o caso nem futebol de areia
também não e pessoas
eu sou muito eclética aparentemente eu
gosto do deputado alessandro molon do
filósofo barulho espinosa e de ariana
grande
acho ok retiro que diz facebook você
acertou direitinho mas brincadeiras à
parte também gosta de presidente do
brasil é interessante que nenhum deles
qualquer um deles está ótimo
e aí pessoal eu realmente mundo vocês a
fazerem essa viagem de autoconhecimento
ou pelo menos do que os outros conhecem
de vocês aí vocês vão ver quais são as
empresas que se comunicam com vocês
quais são as empresas que a rede social
imagina que vocês teriam interesse em
uma olhadinha passei pela dinâmica de
customização de anúncios
acho que é uma forma de vocês entenderem
como privacidade interessa como proteção
de dados é importante e interessante que
o próprio mark zuckerberg tenha dito lá
atrás em 2010 e privacidade já não era
mais uma norma social porque todo mundo
gosta de compartilhar
curiosamente o mesmo mark zuckerberg
nesse ano disse que o futuro do facebook
é mais privacidade
depois de todos os escândalos envolvendo
o vazamento de dados pessoais é
interessante perceber como em nove anos
o debate privacidade ganhou maturidade
como esse debate cresceu e vale lembrar
a gente se vocês não estão pagando por
um determinado produto como costuma se
dizer que o produto pode ser você e aí
um outro tema que interessa para o
debate sobre privacidade e proteção de
dados é o avanço
câmeras de reconhecimento facial ea
utilização dos nossos rostos para as
mais diferentes situações
vale lembrar que isso não é ficção
científica no carnaval do brasil no rio
e em salvador
nós já tivemos testes pilotos feitos com
reconhecimento facial e inclusive no
carnaval de salvador ficou conhecido o
caso do camarada que foi vestido de
mulher e foi preso porque ele era
procurado pela polícia assim como temos
outras situações em que até mesmo em
centros comerciais já se começa a fazer
uma identificação da pessoa que lá
transita enfim com um banco de dados da
polícia é bom entender gente que nós
estamos acostumados a pagar tudo hoje
com cartão de crédito cada vez mais a
gente começa a migrar para biometria a
impressão digital tem uma diferença
muito grande entre o cartão de crédito
ea impressão digital seu cartão de
crédito fraudados semana emitiu outro se
a sua biometria começa a ser fraudada é
seu não tem como impedir permitiu outra
então dados biométricos são muito
importante e quando a gente caminha para
reconhecimento facial a gente precisa
entender quem é que vai ter acesso aos
nossos dados biométricos quem é que vai
ter acesso aos nossos dados
reconhecimento facial e o que vai ser
feito com esses dados
me parece que começa a existir uma certa
conscientização com relação a esse tema
porque na brincadeira do chamado desafio
dos dez anos muita gente começou a
entrar em pânico para quem não se lembra
o desafio dos dez anos na brincadeira em
rede social em que a pessoa que estava
uma foto de 2009 e uma foto de 2019
não sei o que você faria isso mas enfim
essa brincadeira e muitas pessoas
começaram a dizer isso é uma armadilha
na verdade é para treinar técnicas de
aprendizado de máquina pautadas em
padrões de envelhecimento porque se você
está fazendo isso em milhões de pessoas
fazem isso no mundo inteiro é tudo que
uma máquina precisa pra começar a
treinar padrões de envelhecimento eu não
quero que você saiba aqui paranóicos e
eu não vim aqui enfim se absolutamente
disseminar um niilismo entre vocês com
relação ao futuro da tecnologia
mas gostaria que vocês parasse e
prestassem atenção e não saíssem fazendo
é check in
um foto com self a todo momento e
entendendo se preocupando quem é que
coleta esses dados
onde é que esses dados são armazenados e
o que pode ser feito com esses dados
e aí vale lembrar o brasil aprovou uma
nova lei de proteção de dados uma lei
geral de proteção de dados foi aprovado
em 2018 entra em vigor em 2020 e essa
lei traz algumas ferramentas poderosas
que vale a pena vocês conhecerem que
vale a pena vocês se informarem e por
que essa lei é importante porque o
brasil não tem uma cultura de proteção
de dados pessoais
o brasileiro geralmente não se importa
muito com a questão de dados pessoais
principalmente quando na imprensa quase
que toda semana a gente escuta dizer que
uma empresa ou alguma determinada
entidade governamental teve dados
vazados e aí é curioso porque é difícil
você construir uma cultura de dados
pessoais através das repetidas infrações
a essa a esses dados pessoais mas parece
que caminhamos nem 2018 tema da redação
do enem foi manipulação de dados dos
usuários na internet o que mostra o
início de uma preocupação com proteção
de dados
mas aí eu queria fazer um alerta porque
quando se fala em manipulação como
apareceu na redação do enem
a gente está olhando apenas o copo meio
cheio a gente tá olhando o aspecto
negativo é bom lembrar que com dados
pessoais o big data se faz muita coisa
se personalizar experiências empresas
desenvolvem modelos de negócio em cima
disso saber o equilíbrio é a missão de
todos nós que vamos poder usar a lei
3709 ao nosso favor e entender como ela
pode empoderar os usuários para que eles
conheçam mais os seus direitos
então em 2020 você passa a ter a partir
da lei o direito de saber quais são os
dados que estão sendo tratados por
empresas e governos retificar dados que
estão sendo tratados caso estejam sendo
tratados de forma errada a pagar esses
dados transferir esse estado de uma
empresa a outra uma situação de
portabilidade como existe portabilidade
de número de celular
temos portabilidade de dados pessoais
são direitos que vocês precisam conhecer
e mais reconhecer se importar com eles e
exercê los porque nós caminhamos cada
vez mais no futuro no qual os dados
formam o alicerce de uma nova economia
hoje em dia toda empresa é uma empresa
de dados de forma maior ou menor
toda empresa coleta armazena e utiliza
dados pessoais e justamente por isso
quando se diz que dados pessoais são um
novo petróleo a gente vai dar um passo
atrás e entender que na verdade esse
petróleo que se fala é retirado de cada
um de nós esse petróleo na verdade vêm
de pessoas humanas que têm a sua rotina
que tem o seu dia a dia
minerado analisado para chegar a uma
determinada conclusão e digo isso não
para causar medo mas apenas para alertá
los que esse é um tema pelo qual vale a
pena se interessar conhecer e lutar e
não me venha dizer isso é especialmente
importante num país como o brasil em que
grandes cidades são muito inseguras em
que a gente vai simplesmente dizer que
em nome da segurança
nós preferimos a abrir mão da
privacidade ea proteção de dados como
uma frase muito famosa costuma dizer
aquele que diz que não precisa defender
a privacidade porque não tem nada a
esconder
é o mesmo que dizer eu não preciso
defender a liberdade de expressão porque
eu não tenho nada a dizer obrigado
pessoal
[Aplausos]